vamos a las noticias de la salud con
Mara Romero salamar Buen día para usted
Buen día Ángela en el mismo día que se
cumplen tres años del brexit vamos a
hablar de otras crisis del Reino Unido
que vivirá en febrero una nueva oleada
de protestas de los trabajadores de la
salud cuéntenos que se sabe de eso sí
también vamos a hablar del brexit y del
impacto que ha tenido sobre la salud
pero empecemos con estas huelgas que
están convocadas para el uno para el 6
de febrero aunque ya han habido varias
en los meses anteriores en diciembre y
enero sobre todo de los sectores de
enfermería y de las ambulancias
básicamente piden mejores salarios a
raíz de la inflación pero también para
poder hacer el trabajo más atractivo ya
que una de las cosas que denuncian es
que las personas están dejando sus
empleos de forma constante y masiva y
están perdiendo Pues mano de obra para
hacer frente a un sistema de salud que
además cada vez está con más presión a
raíz del covid-19 y de las crisis de
salud pero también porque el nhs que es
como se conoce el sistema de salud
Público de Reino Unido y que solía hacer
una de las joyas de la corona está
teniendo que hacer frente a unos
distintos una población cada vez más
envejecida que requiere otro tipo de
cuidados al que no estaban acostumbrados
no risís una que el Primer Ministro
prometió 3.300 millones de libras
anuales más para el presupuesto para un
total de 192 mil millones de libras que
sería alrededor de 240 mil millones de
dólares pero no ha especificado nada
sobre salarios aunque regionalmente han
habido algunos avances escuchamos los
testimonios de las personas que están
protestando
hay mucho trabajo y estamos bajo presión
La carga del trabajo es cada vez más y
la moral está baja
la moral está baja el personal están
aprietos y cuando llegan a casa no
pueden dar cuidado y comida a sus
familias
Cuando llegamos al primer paciente
quizás lleva esperando 12 horas luego
necesitan ir al hospital y tenemos que
esperar unos 12 horas más para que
puedan traer
Este no es mi trabajo me quedo sentada
fuera de un hospital escuchando llamadas
de emergencia Es que no puedo responder
Vamos a repasar por favor algunas de las
claves de la salud pública en Reino
Unido Sí hemos hemos compilado algunas
cifras para entender mejor Por qué hay
estas protestas y esta crisis no por
ejemplo en octubre de 2022 se registró
el récord de personas en listas de
espera 7,1 millones de personas en todo
el país y el 5,5% de estas llevaban
esperando más de un año para atención
hospitalaria también según estimaciones
del Royal college of emergency medicine
entre 300 y 500 muertes semanales se
pueden atribuir precisamente a estos
retrasos del que hoy vamos a hablar de
los servicios de ambulancias o de otros
servicios de emergencia en el personal
de enfermería 40.000 personas dejaron su
trabajo en 2021 y hay 2,3 camas por mil
habitantes que es un tercio por ejemplo
de las que existen en Francia si lo
comparamos con el resto de países
europeos o un cuarto de las que existen
en Alemania entonces bueno Esto nos
muestra un poco esta fotografía de un
sistema público en aprietos claro y lo
decíamos al principio que otro de los
factores que han influido en la salud en
el Reino Unido ha sido precisamente el
brexit No claro ha tenido varios
impactos sobre todo económicos como
hablábamos también con nuestro compañero
de economía y pues primero es que
contribuye no a una crisis económica que
no ayuda a que haya más dinero por
ejemplo para invertir en recursos
públicos como la salud tampoco ni a que
las personas con menos recursos tengan
dinero para invertirle a medicamentos a
vivir estilos de vida más saludables con
los problemas de salud a largo plazo que
esto va a conllevar Pero hay otra
consecuencia y se trata del acceso a los
medicamentos no vemos este gráfico que
muestra algo que se llama concesiones de
precio para medicinas importadas que es
cuando se notifica que no se encuentra
un medicamento al precio regulado por la
por el nhs no entonces vemos que después
de 2016 empieza a aumentar a tener a
fluctuar arriba y abajo 2016 fue el
momento del referéndum y que en 2022
explota totalmente no se puede atribuir
únicamente al brexit pero es uno de los
factores que que son preponderantes
vamos a terminar en otro tono con buenas
noticias con las victorias que celebró
la OMS en su reunión de junta anual si
vamos a terminar brevemente con esto
porque hay una reunión que durará toda
la semana de los directivos de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud y el
director tedros habría ayer con algunos
de estos logros no por ejemplo el 48% de
las mujeres y personas que dan Pues a
mamar a sus niños ya están dando
solamente exclusivamente antes de los
seis meses de edad el 48% de las mujeres
lo están haciendo algo que tiene
beneficios a largo plazo tanto para los
niños como para las madres y estamos muy
cerca del objetivo del 50% que está
marcado para los próximos años también
la OMS dio servicios de salud mental a 5
millones de personas en varios países
entre ellos Ucrania que sabemos que es
uno de los problemas que están
enfrentando también la nueva vacuna
contra la malaria aprobada en 2021 se
administró a 1,2 millones de niños esto
ha reducido un 10% la mortalidad
infantil por malaria y hay ocho países
la mayoría africanos que han eliminado
una enfermedad tropical desatendida en
el 2022 así que bueno sabemos que hay
cosas que están difíciles pero que
también hay esfuerzos que están dando
sus frutos sí Yo diría que nos quedamos
cortos pero por qué no hay que celebrar
también las cosas buenas por supuesto
gracias a ustedes más gracias Ángela